Oh April Fool's Day it's here again and  the stars are out to play  when Stefani tried to pull a fast one on  us by joking she's pregnant  presumably with Blake Shelton's baby of  course the 46 year old shared a photo of  a sonogram with the caption it's a girl  you're better than this when why don't  you take a cue from John Stamos the  fuller house star had us fooled with  this hilarious trailer for a faux  Netflix documentary fittingly titled  Stamos a human being who is John Stamos  teenage heartthrob  well worldwide brand  what is a star a bad boy a good guy  can we please make this doc happen  meanwhile Iggy Azalea tells I Heart  Radio she's ready to start a family like  now being really getting into cooking  noodles I hear it's really good for  fertility you're you're starting a  family here you want to be sorry I know  you are I make desserts I know you are  okay good just being weird you're being  weird acting like it's a joke